[Music]
my name is sheryl rex i'm the mother of
one's corporal dylan ryan roland
i'm olivia hernandez and i'm
the assistant planned to purple dylan
hi i'm warren masaluka i'm dylan's
grandfather
and my name is clarinda matsuoka and i
am dylan's grandmother
growing up dylan was a very happy child
he never let anything really bother him
he was always smiling and caring towards
everybody around him
yeah he's a fun-loving kid
nothing really seemed to get to him
yeah just always wanted to have fun
smiling well he always loved the
military he was very enthralled with
every aspect of
the armed services
and we have a military family
both my husband and i
our
fathers are we're in the military a lot
of our relatives are in the military so
growing up knowing that it's god and
country that was
where he laid his
his thoughts
and then that
i remember him running around
with his little nerf guns um thinking he
was a soldier and he just would laugh
and he goes one day
i'm going to be in the service during
high school dylan
did want to go to college
he
i asked him to go to college before he
joined the military but he at 17 and a
half
came over to uh or the recruiter came to
the house and
he knew he was going to join the marine
corps before going to college dylan went
to mcrd san diego for a boot camp
um
he loved it
he loved it a lot he was so excited to
come out of boot camp and further into
his
next schooling
during boot camp they're not allowed to
make phone calls home
they do allow them to make one two
minute phone call
during that two-minute phone call i
could hear it in dylan's voice that he
was
something had happened and that was the
point when i
went down for family day to spend the
day with him he said that two minute
phone call was his
breaking point where
they
[Music]
they really push them to see if this is
where they want to be mentally
joining the marine corps changed my son
from
being that child to turning into a young
man
and it felt like that 13 weeks of boot
camp he came out a completely different
person defining moment
yes the pictures that we do have
um
the day of graduation
he was
ecstatic
all the stories that he had um
the smile on his face was bigger than
life itself
he showed us his medals he showed us all
around
told us stories within the museum
everything that he had learned
i don't know that that fire that passion
that glow was
so intense so we all
remarked about it
and
he was in his element
he was so proud
we were all so proud he
i noticed when we picked him up there
was a different glow in his eyes
and he knew what he was
going to do
was going to change
him he was going to learn new things he
was going to meet new friends and
ultimately become a correspond to those
my brothers
he had a
direction to go into
he had a purpose
he knew what he wanted to do and he was
he cured himself a lot differently
the last conversation
i had with dylan he was
packing up
they were in jordan they were packing up
heading afghanistan
he was really excited to get the
opportunity to go there but
we were all
very
concerned
so excited to go help
a lot of other people to freedom and to
safety
they had been watching some of the
videos
online that were happening in
afghanistan and
they were all eager and excited to go
help of course he had grown up knowing
about afghanistan
and
he was so excited again to
be part of that freedom
just to help others
have what we have it here in america
during the last day of august 26th
there was a group of marines
out on abigail and
they were hot and tired
and so
someone in his platoon
replaced that
someone had only been on the wall
for about 20 minutes before the
one went off
he was bending over picking up a child
to safety
[Music]
if donald's here today i was talking how
proud i am of him
or
just having the courage to join the
marine corps first of all because
there's not very many people that would
be willing
to assign their life
to the marine corps or military at all
one percent of americans
to sign up to defend our country
so i would definitely tell him how very
proud i am of him
and
leading into
the withdrawal of afghanistan
i would also tell him that he saved so
many lives
being an american is
to live by freedom
which
many countries don't have
we're free
to go to a grocery store
full of food we can go to an amusement
park we can go to the beach we can go to
the mountains
we can
have a gun and go shooting at a range
that's what freedom is
and that's what he wanted for others
and that's why even with him going to
afghanistan
and his proud moments with his team
they wanted to give people that
opportunity to come to america
and live like him
and that's why we say live like dylan
you